[Music]
in mega party news mega mega submitted
by pata cap
police are investigating several
hospitalizations after a party at
youtuber Jake Paul's house Oh cares dude
well people went to the hospital did we
gotta care about people I hope they all
died though okay good being was a drug
thing
actually I don't know I just say mean
things what happened does this mean but
it's okay I'm thinking it's a drug thing
if you guys want to see David fight Jake
Paul put in the comments below I want to
see David get his ass kicked by anyone I
don't care anyone Wednesdays and from on
Fridays we all spar each other we all
get ass I should go trade and that would
be my goal to beat David that that'd be
tight I'm not afraid of that kid Jake
lady's older brother yeah his butt all
over the way better than him okay we're
having insight conversations I don't
know the bookies they're talking about
they're talking about Jake and Logan
policy does it feel threatened by Jake
getting Logan's Way more Logan Logan
versus no I think Logan would kick my
ass no Frank didn't do any like
wrestling or anything like Logan well
did you maybe watch the fights you saw a
move I saw a movie moves terrible I
don't watch it like Logan even though
he's like a shitty amateur he still
kicked my ass though
like hands wise the moves well I'm not
gonna go in and get my ass beat and talk
a lot of [ __ ] I saw him move he's really
athletic too that's really cool I like
that you know yourself yeah but I still
shoot him in the [ __ ] face hey both
you could borrow my gun not my
compliment if you attack me oh I don't
know the guy popcorn you like my goat
man I don't know I mean they could be
really cool people what else if the
opportunity came for me to box that kid
for a gazillion dollars yeah I do it you
Jillian I'm doing anything free I do it
for free oh you [ __ ] up the market they
gotta go down there like a [ __ ] Julia
it's like over here it's like my demands
are two million dollars just in the back
I'll do it for free
all right so Jake Paul threw a birthday
party for designer you guys know the
rapper oh the rapper your friends
they're buds like that you got a lot of
friends don't [ __ ] boy start so he
threw a party for him in his Calabasas
home and there were a [ __ ] ton of people
that were there and a lot of celebrities
too apparently Chris Brown other people
but other people I like that I don't
know he was that interconnected with the
celebrities apparently yeah yeah that's
tight well when you have money you're
connected anybody
fun fact though we went to an MMA fight
and they were sitting a few rows behind
us behind so we had more clout than them
I was like yeah we have more cloud than
them dude paint it I could barely get
William Hung coming my birthday dude
that guy got bad as [ __ ] man
yo somebody took a picture with him
Julie oh yeah dude she look like you're
stung by a thousand bees can you pull it
up what a happy Lea
Julia Julia I'm Julia and Julia and you
know June applause it's a journal Morris
he [ __ ] let himself anyway so yeah Oh
Lamar Odom and Trey Songz were also
there damn that's crazy
so designer is turning 22 I do actually
I thought he was older than that his
voice sounds like he's 55 like he's been
smoking for 30 years his voice is very
interesting deep this is how the music
goes
what when he's exhaling his while look
how rich they are that's very rare is
that Jay Paul's house yeah that's just
looks like a church that's very rich I
don't get why there's one gold balloon
over here though it's a string you're
poor dude you don't understand art dude
come on down it was a mistake in his
backyard you had motocross and a boxing
ring
who was boxing that's what they were
using when they were training weren't
they I don't know okay let me sit where
is this full lid that you can help asses
there is more room out there ballers
lives there's this Facebook post from it
was posted to moms of Conejo Valley and
it says it gonna go badly I know how
come you didn't do it Calabasas
Calabasas it clear that was Calabasas
we're rabbit in Spanish so I had to save
my planet for oh we usually hear
Calabasas the gringo way I usually go
tonnage oh I don't hear gonna hold up
this is Calabasas a Spanish word
Calabasas pumpkins and corn mo means
rabbit yeah baby
I'm making my menu for my restaurant
because I'm trying to put some size
Calabar so how do gringos say conical
Valley neo Conejo Cornejo belly like
they posted this on Facebook it says a
big warning to those with teenage
daughters my daughter was at a party in
Calabasas last night and she got food
for youtuber Jake Hall the house was a
mansion filled with young people she
ended up in the hospital with 8 other
girls who had been drugged at West Hills
Hospital incoherent something was put in
their drinks the girls were all
half-naked and unable to walk or talk
they were made to sign a disclaimer at
the door I'm sharing this in hopes that
you will talk to your teens and young
adults I'm sharing this and hopes to
help someone I will be reporting this to
the authorities oh [ __ ] dude I really
hope you know I have nothing against
Jake Paul I don't know him but it would
be awesome if you went to jail you just
like to see people fail yeah it's fun
it's fun that's having something against
someone right no it's not because he
could show it's like random it could be
anybody yeah anybody say anybody that's
anybody's more money but yeah anyone
that's successful oh those are called
trolls yes
ah so you're the people you hate no but
I'm not doing it I'm just on the
sidelines doing this that's sure a an
indifferent troll is better than a like
a active troll [ __ ] I'm not creating
this so-called energy I'm laughing at
the energy failure it's like a fait
accompli it's like what we do here on JK
news you can't hope for someone it just
has to happen
I don't mind you can't hope for it can't
hope for it but he's kind of hoping for
this like cocky kid man yeah but that's
why I'm saying it's more fun with
somebody like that
they don't mean like he's just I don't
know if he's mean but I saw one video of
him where he was trying to I guess he
was trying to articulate himself and
explain why he is the way he is and it
just made me think oh you're actually
really a dummy so now he's a kid now
that he's dumb it makes it even funnier
so now that a dump is having 222 yeah so
he's designer and him are the same
yeah designer just carries himself like
more of an adult yes I did yeah well I
mean regardless of actually he's older
semi young successful people there's
like eight chicks in the hospital from
getting drugs and I like half-made it's
interesting cuz like with all of that
celebrity and it just all the all the
clout that people have there it almost
seems like they can all get laid
why do they have to drug girls yeah
that's weird huh the reason why this
made the news is because of all these
big names attached to this party but
it's not known who was the person
drugging could have just been another
attendee other parties why this family
then what's that well I mean the
disclaimer just doesn't seem convenient
then and you know what though the weird
thing is what is Lamar Odom doing there
you're [ __ ] 50 years old dude get the
[ __ ] you were probably roofing everybody
up oh he's not with the Kardashian girl
I don't think so
I think I kept moving on with another
basketball player oh really I don't know
I don't remember I just know that Lamar
Odom and one of the Kardashians had a
reality show and it'd be peace yeah
Khloe
Oh Khloe an Odom is that what it was Oh
Clawd him alright cuz then Tristan
cheated owners yeah she had a baby Kim
oh my bad oh she loves basketball dick
yeah so do I it comes with a lot of
dollars a lot of weight yeah balls so
that's why this has been making me worse
because I did it his name please just
haven't go to jail dude that'd be so fun
I mean every time something happens at a
celebrity party something you know
everyone has to talk about it because
like I remember Pam Anderson she had a
like birthday party for her kid and
somebody died in the pool oh [ __ ] for
real a kid died in a poo Jay Paul's
representatives he's saying that the
party planner had hired 38 security
officers who checked everybody's IDs and
they were in not really well
I know because big ideas they didn't
check the stash of drugs those next to
it well not only that but it seemed like
there are a lot of like underage people
here maybe they have fake IDs to who
know maybe that's true I could imagine
like if I was like a teen
and I heard there's a celebrity party
down the street I'm trying to get some
celebrity come yeah I would try to get
it I was trying to [ __ ] anything to get
in there
I'm trying to [ __ ] get child support
you know for me as a parent I would
definitely not put it out on Facebook
that my kid went there because it's more
of a reflection yeah what the sigh so
you let your kid go to a party full of
drugs and [ __ ] you like go ahead Britney
it's all good she was a cool mom that's
why oh my god yes are you condoms
condoms she left she left she let her
daughter go or my daughter just went
with tough situation you know what I
mean yeah you you know what don't talk
to your daughter you what you should do
is go to the hospital and look for a
girl who just got drugged and raped and
then have her talk to your daughter
ah that's that's how you first they were
just in church away dude yeah that's the
straight way yeah cuz they're not gonna
listen to you you're gonna be like yeah
whatever man I'm smart and then you pull
out the part where it's like you want to
know the real truth yeah or an accent
yeah I went to a party it had you and in
son sons don't know child support sons
don't get away with it either you take
them to jail and you say who's the
biggest rapist here and if you talk you
talk my kid I like how when he asked
that question someone's like who's
raises his head outside of the cell I am
just huge of this like soft voice me can
you talk to my son
[Music]